All right, let's get into audience questions
for the week.
Just days left until the election.
Many election related questions, including
first and foremost, David, I've heard you
criticize Donald Trump's response to the virus.
And I agree with you.
It has been terrible.
But if Joe Biden becomes president in January,
what should he do then?
That Donald Trump has not done so.
Two part question, first of all, is the vast
majority of the things that should have been
done should have been done previously.
And this includes establishing contact tracing
early on, building testing capacity early
on the way that South Korea did, telling the
truth early on about the seriousness of the
virus.
A lot of these things in other words, most
people now understand the seriousness of the
virus.
There's less to do on that front, although
you still have a lot of Trump's followers
who don't believe it.
It would be great to have to have a president
who tells the truth.
But there is no question that the time to
do things was 20/20, not 20 or 21, which is
when Joe Biden will actually get to do something.
Now, by January 21st, hopefully we would start
to be on the other side of Spike number three,
which is building right now.
Hopefully by January 21st, there will already
be some people vaccinated and more people
getting vaccinated every day.
So the things that Joe Biden will have to
sort of think about or contend with will be,
number one, restoring our public health officials
who are actually infectious disease specialists
to positions where they are speaking to the
country.
Dr. Anthony Foushee was removed from that
position by Trump and blocked from doing interviews
and so on and so forth.
He put in neuro radiologist Scott Atlas, who
wants herd immunity and questions, masks and
whatever else.
So we've got to change who is publicly speaking
to the country from the standpoint of public
health.
Stop lying about the virus.
Constantly get a stimulus bill done.
If indeed we need one January 21st.
And that's something that a President Biden
would have to look at, evaluate whether the
request for mask mandates should be made.
Remember, the consensus constitutionally seems
to be that a president cannot federally mandate
everybody wear a mask.
There would be two ways to do it.
One is a president would say to all 50 governors,
hey, guys and gals, please do mask mandates.
If we all do this for six weeks.
We will dramatically reduce the spread.
It would be up to governors to do it or work
with Congress so that through the Commerce
Clause court, Congress can regulate commerce
in such a way that would allow some kind of
mass mandate.
But a president unilaterally doing it doesn't
appear as though they can do it.
This is the way we'd have to be done.
Biden's going to have to evaluate the situation
if and when he gets sworn in and go from there.
You know, things like a national contact tracing
system.
The unfortunate reality, it would be great
to do it.
The unfortunate reality is that contact tracing,
once you have overwhelming communities spread
where even relatively rural parts of the country
have a huge number of cases.
Contact tracing becomes less important at
a at a systemic public health level.
It should still be done.
But again, the time to do it was in February
and March.
Increased transparency on the numbers because
now many people don't trust the numbers actually
work with other countries, as opposed to saying,
we're blocking China, we're blocking Europe.
Everybody that Americans get blocked from
going places actually start to work with other
countries on a coordinated response, planning
for what things will start to look like as
we can hopefully at some point next year,
begin to loosen travel guidelines, so on and
so forth, assure us of the safety of the vaccine
in a trustworthy way.
As you all know, without being anti vax, anybody
who has followed the lies of Trump would be
skeptical about saying on Trump's say so that
a vaccine is safe.
So there are lots of things to be done.
But we also have to recognize that we talk
about climate change, irreversible damage.
And when someone else comes in, they have
to start trying to clean up a situation that
was worsened, not under their watch.
A lot of the things on coronavirus had to
be done when Australia did them, when New
Zealand did them, when South Korea did them,
when Taiwan did the Bangladesh, etc. by the
time Joe Biden is in office.
Those things aren't the things anymore.
And it will be about figuring out going forward
how to restore trustworthiness and a sense
of professionalism to the White House in its
coronavirus response.
And it's going to be an uphill battle, there's
no doubt about it.
But every day, every day we wait is another
day.
Trump's federal government pushes us in the
wrong direction